you have missed most of all stars three  airing this week is the twist reveal  I've decided to audition a few other  girls what can we expect  what do you tease me am i it's been so  bizarre not being able to watch week  after week even though I was there to  tape all-stars for drag race this season  is phenomenal if you think you've seen  it all get prepared to be shocked at  what happens in the remaining episodes  of this season and they also announced  that we're gonna get season 10 right  after all-stars 3 season 10 is up even a  level further from where we have been I  don't know how RuPaul does it but ruin  the team have managed to take the show  to a level I'm talking quality of oMG  that you've ever seen season ten might  be my favorite season ever be number one  [Music]